حين الاحساس بالغضب او التوتر الكلمه
الاكثر شيوعا هي ارتفاع الضغط اي عدم
القدره على التحمل اكثر لكن بالفعل ارتفاع
ضغط الدم هو مرض خطير يتسلل خفيه احيانا
لدرجه عدم معرفه الاصابه به فمنظمه الصحه
العالميه قدرت عدد المصابين بارتفاع ضغط
الدم حول العالم بمليار و280 مليون شخص
غير ان
46% من ضحاياه يجهلون الاصابه بهم يعد ضغط
الدم خطرا ان ترك دون علاج اي عند ارتفاعه
في الاوعيه الدمويه الى 90 على 140 ملم
زئبقيا او حتى اكثر من ذلك حينها تكون قوه
دفع الدم باتجاه جدران الشرايين عاليه
للغايه باستمرار ما يجهد القلب اكثر خلال
ضخ الدم وبالتالي يستوجب الرعايه الطبيه
الطارئه العوامل المسببه بعضها قابل
للتغيير كنظام غذائي وصحي واخرى لا يمكن
تغييرها
كعامل الوراثه اي السوابق العائليه وتجاوز
سن الخامسه وستين عاما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات